[Música]
[Aplausos]
atreverte a hacer el 90 por ciento de
una distancia y esperar que la otra
persona haga el restante 10 dicen que
este es el secreto de un gran beso de
película lanzarte al vacío y cruzar los
dedos para que haya química y al final
de espere el calor de un aliento y no
una cobra suena verdad
pues una sensación similar acompaña a
miles de personas cada día pero dura
mucho más que los cinco segundos del
beso puede llegar a durar años son
personas que deciden dejar su hogar
original por sus motivaciones e
inquietudes para construir uno nuevo en
otro país con las personas de allí
y así se convierten en transmigrantes
son personas que llaman casa a dos o más
sitios a la vez y que pasan a vivir por
encima de una frontera entre culturas y
estados suelen ser personas ambiciosas
inquietas con una gran capacidad de
adaptación y resiliencia y sin embargo
al mismo tiempo son
expatriadas solitarias sospechosas
extrañas ajenas intrusos y aliens
representan un 20 por ciento de la
población de barcelona una quinta parte
y 18 de ellos viven en el eixample con
lo cual podríamos decir que es un 15 o
20 por ciento de esta sala
un árabe en nueva york'
un uruguayo en madrid o una rusa en
barcelona
os habéis preguntado alguna vez lo que
supone para ellos convertirse en un
miembro de la comunidad local que
esfuerzo requiere ser uno más
tengo derecho a elegir
me dejaran entrar allí donde yo elija
yo sí me lo he preguntado porque suena
transmigrante y tras años de vivir lejos
de mi país tras haber cambiado ciudades
bares de debajo de casa celebraciones
populares he llegado a la conclusión de
que el hecho de ser miembro de una
comunidad local no solo se consigue por
el hecho de nacimiento también se puede
conseguir con voluntad y aceptación
voluntad de aceptación tanto del que
llega y quiere entrar como del que
recibe y puede abrir la puerta
para que el beso ocurra el recién
llegado tiene que querer aprender y
adaptarse pero también tiene que aceptar
que el puente lo tendrá que atender el y
curarse el discurso de entrada y aceptar
el sacrificio de dejar cosas atrás
y aceptar nuevos ritos y transformarse y
jugar diferente
y el autóctono para hacer su viaje al
encuentro tiene que querer establecer
este vínculo de local a local y también
tiene que aceptar su papel de guía tiene
que valorar esta variedad que pueden
traer los nuevos locales consigo no solo
para tolerar la sino para aprender de la
diversidad del contraste y es el
contraste el que suele dar miedo porque
qué pasa si son tan diferentes que no me
voy a saber explicar y no me van a
entender
como voy a dejar entrar a este intruso
si va a traer lo suyo y se cargará lo
mío
pues ahí es donde nos confundimos porque
muchas de las culturas tal y como las
conocemos hoy en día son fruto de las
sinergias entre los de toda la vida y
los intrusos porque los intrusos poco a
poco se van convirtiendo en los de toda
la vida mientras van viniendo unos
nuevos el concepto de la pureza ya no
tiene sentido es obsoleto en la
innovación pasa lo mismo porque el
progreso y la creatividad ocurren en una
frontera en el punto de encuentro otro
transmigrante el maestro jorge drexler
el uruguayo en madrid dice que las cosas
solo son puras cuando uno las mira desde
lejos y todos en el fondo somos de
ningún lado del todo y de todos lados un
poco
lo bueno del contraste es que nos
permite aprender los unos de los otros
resalta estas cosas bonitas que nos
gustan de nuestras culturas y de
nosotros mismos pero también revela los
patrones que adaptamos inconscientemente
y que vistos desde una distancia pueden
parecer más trauma que otra cosa
y esta oportunidad de ver y experimentar
estas realidades con otra óptica nos
permite ver matices y en algunos casos
sanar y también nos permite cuidar con
más cariño la parte constructiva
identificadora y de ella revalorar ideas
cuestionar verdades absolutas y
redefinir lo bueno y lo malo os voy a
poner un ejemplo sólo desde que vivo en
este país me dado cuenta de un padrón
que tengo incrustado profundamente por
las generaciones atrás que es el de
dignificación de sufrimiento y
sacrificio
qué bien
en la cultura rusa o soviética se sufre
se sufre en silencio con dignidad con
respeto porque se considera que el
sufrir purifica
y sacrificarte
por los demás o por una idea es lo
esperado es la hazaña de cada día
incluso está más valorado que la
necesidad de ser feliz y está totalmente
normalizado y pasa desapercibido no lo
podéis creer
quizá gracias a esto mi pueblo tiene
tantas historias de superación pero
evidentemente tiene un precio
dicen que sonreímos poco
será verdad
porque no está bien visto mostrar la
felicidad en público a la simple
pregunta de cómo estás
la respuesta más optimista que puedes
recibir es normal
hay una expresión expresión que dice la
felicidad ama el silencio
muy poético pero duro
y vaya a contraste con el vivir
mediterránea mente
gracias a esto me he dado cuenta de que
hay herencias que es mejor dejar atrás
pero también hay otras de las que me
siento muy orgullosa y celebro cada
oportunidad que tengo para compartirlas
de hecho nunca me he sentido tan rusa
como desde que vivo aquí
pero a la vez cada vez me siento más de
barcelona de hecho cuando me voy a
madrid me preguntan si soy catalana por
el acento
ya está ya soy una más
y vivo mi vida en catalán celebro la
diada de sant jordi más que san valentín
tengo mi faja castillera a veces me la
pongo y me hace muy orgullosa que
rosalía es de aquí igual que yo
me parece que estoy empezando a
disfrutar de mi gran beso de película
con esta ciudad
pero también hay que decir que para
llegar aquí y superar mi largo y duro 90
de distancia he tenido que estar muchos
años aprendiendo y demostrando incluso
me saque una carrera para tener las
herramientas necesarias
aún así mis compañeros transmigrantes y
yo tenemos que luchar alguna que otra
batalla para defender nuestro estatus de
local
en mi caso quizás sería un poquito más
fácil si mi nombre sería más
internacional y pasaría desapercibida
de vez en cuando alguien me viene y me
pregunta
desde aquí verdad
master y tú de dónde eres
y en este momento mi cabeza hace
todo mi camuflaje para pasar por una
niña de barrio
amigo accent aviv las frases tretas de
las canciones de los amigos de las artes
ya está
me han excluido ya no soy parte del
grupo de los de aquí
a ver cómo se lo explico porque ojalá a
su siguiente comentario sea qué bonito
san petersburgo fui y me encantó
o se decir la palabra espejo en ruso ser
cola porque me encanta esta película de
tarkovski me lo dijeron una vez y casi
me echó a llorar de lo bonito del
momento
pero también me encuentro con los
comentarios como el de los polvorones
los osos el frío la política
y otros tantos y también alguna grada
que ni me atrevo explicar aquí
suelen ser unos 15 minutos de
conversación vacía absurda incómoda que
sinceramente no aportan nada a nadie y a
mí me aburre pero es allí donde me
agarro a la oportunidad de salvar la
situación e intentar darle la vuelta y
en lugar de decir soy de rusia que es la
respuesta que busca mi interlocutor digo
soy rusa pero vivo aquí en barcelona
y este pero a mí me pesa un poco porque
no debería estar allí
cómo podemos hacer que esta conversación
sea más inclusiva y beneficiosa para los
dos os propongo cambiar la pregunta
podemos decir eres de aquí
independientemente del acento de la
apariencia de la persona porque esta es
una pregunta generosa que abre puertas
que brinda reconocimiento y entonces ahí
yo diría si vivo en barcelona y además
mis raíces están en rusia y ya veremos
dónde se manifiesta el contraste si es
gastronomía si es cultura si es la
manera de entender la felicidad pero a
partir de ahí conectaremos y empezaremos
a construir juntos y nos trataremos como
iguales
mi terapeuta dice que tendemos a hacer
este tipo de preguntas porque las
personas necesitamos encasillar a los
otros
necesitamos encajar a todo el mundo en
un sistema de casillas de bueno malo
blanco negro lo nuestro lo de los otros
pero qué pasa si no hay una casilla para
los transmigrantes
si compartimos la identidad fronteriza
pero cada persona tiene una combinación
distinta de culturas y experiencias de
hecho podemos ir más allá y decir que
los autóctonos también igual y les
podemos llamar trans autóctonos y si
rascamos bien veremos que son
descendientes de algún transmigrante por
muy lejano que sea
me gusta decir o pensar bueno os lo digo
a vosotros
que los transmigrantes tenemos un
superpoder
es el de ser traductores de fronteras
porque podemos hacer que lo que está más
allá de la frontera se vea diferente que
los que están a cada lado se entiendan y
se vean mejor
los tres autóctonos también tienen otro
que es el de hacer la frontera invisible
disimularla para que la misión de
integrarse no sea imposible
y mi sueño es que cada vez más personas
dominen estos superpoderes porque cada
día vemos muchas más oportunidades para
que la gente empiece este camino y si no
sois vosotros serán vuestros hijos o
amigos y el que recibe hoy a lo mejor
mañana le tocará buscar una puerta
tener que hacer el 90 por ciento del
camino para convertirte en un local es
inasumible es muy duro es largo cansa y
nadie te garantiza el éxito al final
pero para un beso de película
los porcentajes pueden ser los que
queramos depende de los generosos lo
valientes los sensibles y los curiosos
que decidamos ser mirémonos de cerca y
démonos estos besos de película para que
transformen nuestra realidad
[Aplausos]